we must Chris very quickly mentioned
Thor mostly so we can show this picture
sure why don't you be embarrassed god
that's like a lot of dieting and
exercise also for now apparently is this
true the people this is odd so people
come up to you and they want you to tell
a specific joke oh they're just come and
tell me for a joke oh okay like um
yep go uh you know the joke about the
four spends a night with this woman and
the next morning he says I have to tell
you who I am you know I'm Thor she says
you're Thor I can hardly walk the first
time twenty-seven that see Megan I would
have thought your look is quite unique
you would think that wouldn't you you
would I get told I look like everyone's
mate anyone with curly hair and teeth
put a horse in a wig and it's Saturday I
get told I look like Elliott Gould Jerry
Seinfeld Ruud van Nistelrooy Meeker the
donkey from Shrek I have to say though
we have a picture of donkey effect and
you do look remarkably like
separated at birth yeah no someone's
exaggerating then we looked at the
picture was like actually actually it
does someone said to me you don't sound
like him I said well after this Eddie
Murphy
so many bits of this story missing so
you're having sex in a dog basket
there's Stephen his wife I know lots of
hairy men standing around watching you
that's why I imagine what doggin feels
like